what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel today I am going
to be reacting to the Andrew Tate and
Pierce Morgan debate but before I start
do not forget to subscribe to the
channel and ring that notification Bell
that way you're going to be notified of
my daily videos guys my goal is to get
to a million subscribers before the
first of the year that is a very Hefty
goal but I think we can do it so make
sure you subscribe to the channel now
also like the video on your way in
because a like is the most important
metric that YouTube uses to push out
these videos pull up the video blessing
well joining me now is Andrew Tate his
videos have been viewed billions of
Times online I am shocked Andrew came
back I would like to say I'm shocked I
don't know if I was him I would come
back pretty much every mainstream social
media platform including Twitter uh
Andrew welcome back to Piers Morgan
uncensored I like how he doesn't smile
at all I can't such a stone thing
your take on this I think it's quite
interesting because you've been a victim
of being uh victims the right word but
you've been removed from social media
platforms for your opinions
um Elon Musk has dedicated himself he
says to restoring Free Speech shout out
Elon come on my podcast I'd love to
interview you shout out Elon uh do you
think that's going to include you for
example I don't think it matters if it
includes me or not I think what's
important is that free speech is the
number one weapon against absolute
tyranny and although you cannot have
complete Free Speech because then
conversations completely break down into
asinine insult fests I do like the idea
of The Changing of the Guard when it
comes to control over information is it
possible Andrew Tate to actually police
something like Twitter to to be a
platform for genuine Free Speech or is
it so toxic and tribal now that whatever
happens you know before we had all the
people on the right screaming away that
there would be no platformed and so on
now you've got all the people on the
left screaming that they're being no you
know know diminished in some way
it's very tribal very toxic can musk cut
through that and if so how
yeah it's going to be extremely
difficult there's always going to be one
group of people who are extremely
unhappy but I think that anybody who's
perspicacious enough to understand the
truth of what's been going on in the
world recently will know that the left
and their narratives have certainly been
protected for a very long time and the
universe has swings and balances and God
often restores balance to the universe
and perhaps it might swing the other way
for a while I truthfully am a person who
believes that all points of view are
extremely important because as soon as
you block points of view you have
absolute tyranny now he's absolutely
right the left has had control of the
media for so long and people are sick of
it I mean Elon he's voted left in every
single election and now they're saying
that he's right-wing he's not even
right-wing and I just think that free
speech is so important because even if
your idea is bad like let them shout
their bad points of view from the
rooftops and then people will come back
with the correct information like you
don't need someone on top policing
information and in a way it's sort of
self-defeating isn't it because you
carried on getting huge attention it was
interesting to me that when you came on
the show for example we've had yeah
because he's goaded goaded I think
nearly six million people have viewed
the whole interview that we did which is
a huge number of people certainly far
higher than Washington conventional
television so you have a whole you have
a whole world out there online which
operates away from social media
platforms
yeah uh I've been very very successful
in spite of them but not many people can
do that I'm in a pretty unique position
but I think that everybody needs a voice
to a degree and social media platforms
are now the most important platforms on
the planet they control information and
they influence real world decisions and
they influence people's perception of
reality the last few years of covet have
been a perfect example of what happens
when you censor one side of the argument
and you only allow one point of view to
be purported by the Matrix in and of
itself and that's how you end up in
tyrannical situations I think you were
just discussing that pierce yeah and I
think it's perfectly valid point you
know people have quite I think quite
rightly held me to task over some of the
positions I took during the covert
pandemic uh notably when the scientists
said as a definitive fact that you you
couldn't transmit the virus if you had
the vaccine it turned out that wasn't
true yeah okay Pierce but it was new I
don't need a science degree or to know
anything about science to have common
sense and common sense says if it's a
new piece of technology or a new vaccine
it's possible that while you are
learning about the side effects that
they could be wrong and I base my
observations on that supposed fact and
said right but in that case used to be
vaccinated you shouldn't get the same
rights as people who've been vaccinated
if if it's time will always tell the
truth always comes out if you're
unjabbed you can pass it on it turned
out actually there's not much difference
whether you've been back I had a friend
that told me that if I didn't get
vaccinated I couldn't see her kids that
she didn't have I was like why don't you
try getting pregnant first well and at
that point I changed my mind uh but I I
felt that there were a lot of people who
were being de-platformed from Twitter at
the time for questioning the validity of
scientific statements and they would
then be a complete U-turn so I do think
it was a very interesting period I
wonder did Pierce Morgan was did he say
those people should be censored okay so
he said free speech okay I was just
wondering actually for testing what Free
Speech it was actually worse than that
you're right Pierce but it was actually
worse than interesting because what
happens is when you censor an entire
side of the argument and only allowed
one side of the argument to have a voice
you are changing reality in real time
you are shaping the world the only
reason that scam continued as long as it
did and the only reason people didn't
get to see their own parents get buried
and the only reason people sat and
masked missed cancer appointments
because they were scared of the common
cold was because they were censoring
anybody who said anything contrary to
the purported version of events that the
mainstream media decided they want the
entire world to swallow it's beyond
simply interesting and it's beyond
simply uh funny or coincidental yeah I
mean I will challenge you on one thing
it's not the common cold right covid-19
has killed 6.6 million people it is one
of the most deadly viruses certainly of
our lifetime so it wasn't like I had it
it wasn't that bad I mean it was it was
a little worse than the common cold I'm
cold but I do think it is completely
Justified ah don't cancel me don't
cancel me to say we should be more
cautious I think about accepting during
fast-moving pandemics the word of
scientists as being sacrosanct because
on a number of things from the use of
masks to the efficacy of okay this is
something my dad told me there is a time
where I got a piece of advice from
someone and I just thought it was wrong
but this person I knew had been in the
field longer than me I knew this person
knew more than me but I just thought it
wasn't correct and I told my dad this
but I'm like oh he knows more than me
and my dad said so smart people can be
wrong he's not God and so that just gave
me a different point of view and it's
the same thing with Scientists like I'm
all for getting information from people
that know more than you and taking their
opinion in but if it doesn't make sense
with what I'm seeing in the real world
they're not God they don't know
everything scientists can be wrong too
and I think that's like one of the
things that during the pandemic like
everybody didn't realize like scientists
can be bought just because they know
more than you doesn't doesn't mean
they're right and if it doesn't make
sense with what you're seeing like I
didn't know a single person that died
from my real life I don't even know
someone that got close to it so it
doesn't make sense to just blindly trust
people all the time scenes in preventing
transmission they did massive u-turns
I've read enough history books to know
that the people who do the censoring are
never the good guys and they've been
censoring a lot of arguments for a very
long time in the name of good they are
weaponizing virtue and it's always in
the name of tyranny go did it's
absolutely right Godin funny he was out
here trying to silence an entire side of
an argument on any subject whether it's
19 immigration anything else they are
the evil people who are out for absolute
mind control of the populace I certainly
agree I certainly agree that I think the
healthiest thing for any democracy is
for All Views to be aired and debated we
seem to have lost the ability to debate
you know when I interviewed you yeah we
had a few fractious moments but actually
I thought it was a pretty spirited
debate between people who perhaps had
you know preconceived views of each
other I mean yeah you would think that
because you weren't the one getting
interrupted 20 times I guess Andrew Tate
thought that too because he came back
but just like the audacity Pierce come
on my show I'm just saying I'm in
England come on my show no problem
interviewing you now about this because
I think you have an interesting uh take
on this stuff
and that's the key to life when you
reach that level of adolescence in your
mindset where you can't handle any point
of view that is contrary to your own
then you're truly a broken person and
that's what the internet is purporting
it's very interesting you said about
Twitter being tribal there's a large
contingent of people on Twitter who
simply cannot handle reading and opinion
which differs from their own and that
has a degree of immaturity that we do
not need adults to be functioning with
in the modern world no I agree if you're
Elon Musk this idea of charging eight
dollars now a month uh whatever it is to
access the Blue Tick premium Twitter I
say you may as well pay eight dollars a
month for it because people have asked
me why don't get verified on Instagram
because they damn near be given that
check mark out to everybody so we might
you may as well pay eight bucks a month
to be verified you may as well cat would
you do that would you pay the extra and
people already do on Instagram and
there's other platforms and I'm pretty
sure they were paying anyway like that's
what can came forward was that they were
selling verifications anyway so it's
like
if you can buy it anyway they might as
well be open about it I think that
social media companies for a very long
time have lived in an absolute fantasy
where they've printed money from thin
air by charging people for pixels and
they grew into these large conglomerates
with too many staffs sitting around
doing nothing having coffee breaks and
Elon Musk is a businessman he's walked
into the office and he's firing a bunch
of people who are messing around doing
nothing and he wants his business to
make money as it absolutely should and
how he decides that happens is his
prerogative I don't see why we should
sit and accept that website needs 200
000 people sitting around discussing in
Long meetings sitting on bean bags about
policy of human rights of some garbage
when he's come along and said no I'm a
businessman we're going to charge for
our service we're going to reduce the
number of Staff we're going to be a
functional coherent company as they
should be and that's his prerogative to
do it as he's bought the company I think
he can do whatever he wants yeah
okay I have been thinking for a while
that tech companies do nothing because
I'll see these girls on Tick Tock where
it's like what I do in a day at my tech
job and they do damn near nothing I've
worked in a corporate environment and I
was making calls all day I was hitting
the phone lines I was in sales but I'm
like what is your job and it's always
some vague job where you don't actually
know what it means and they literally do
nothing they'll like be playing
ping-pong every day ping pong I don't
disagree because did you play ping pong
at your last shot no blessing do you
play ping pong here no
do you do things every day
you do things Kobe yeah it's like
why you got time to play ping pong okay
we freestyle a little bit sometimes
[ __ ] of the New York Post exclusive
about Hunter Biden the son of the
presidents about his laptop this is
three weeks before the the election that
Joe Biden won uh he was heading you know
to a possible Victory but it was tight
and that story they reckon could have
tipped it either way but it was
completely suppressed and censored uh
starting with Twitter then Facebook then
others Twitter literally locked out the
New York poster car for two weeks for
breaking a completely true story I
thought that was shameful it's worse
than shameful it's worse than shameful
when you control information you control
the real world they affect the real
world in absolute in real time they are
genuinely affecting the reality people
live in they are not just a company
they're not just a social media platform
it affects absolutely every single
person on the planet when it changes who
is elected I don't want to comment
specifically on Hunter Biden or the
laptop I would never kill myself but I
don't don't think it's fair that they
would hide certain key information that
close to an election and the fact that
they've done that was done specifically
to affect to affect the world that we
all live in and we all have to suffer
the consequences of those things so to
sit and say that these companies can
just do whatever they want in their
private Etc no free speech is beyond
important for democracy it's important
for the reality that we exist under I
should say thank you for joining me I
appreciate it now Andrew Tate was
absolutely right it like the media has
been so left for so long that people
just don't even know it's true anymore
and it's not fair to people that we
can't even trust the reporters that are
supposed to be unbiased in giving us
information so I think it's great that
we're starting to see the pendulum swing
the other way and I I am so excited to
see what the goat does with Twitter
which Speaking of which follow my
Twitter um I think the account I forgot
my name I think it's pearly oh pearly
things with a z I'm almost to 10 000
followers on Twitter so you could you
can call me an influencer at
um
um make sure you guys like the video on
your way out and let me know in the
comments what do you guys think of this
interview
um is there anything that take out wrong
let me know subscribe to the channel
ring that notification Bell and I will
talk to you next time as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible